[Applause]
hello everyone and um good afternoon
actually
um welcome to my talk succeeding in the
Life Sciences with our Python and the
cloud before we get started I want to
give a few caveats and considerations so
everything in this talk is public
opinions are my own not my clients or
employers this talk references many
Microsoft uh tools but before you get up
and run away if you're in AWS shop
everything that I talk about is almost
everything I talk about about is going
to be applicable if you use gcp AWS or
something else this content spans
scientific technical academic and
Industry experience um so depending on
which one you're from a lot of this is
applicable kind of Across the Life
Sciences space so don't worry if you're
in Academia or if you're at a Pharma
company got something for
you a little bit about me um my name is
Colby again I am a computational
biologist and Cloud AI architect um I'm
the founder and principal consultant at
tupal we're a Microsoft partner shop
that and we're the only mic Microsoft
partner that exclusively focuses in the
genomic space um in addition I am the
co-founder of Amisa we're an NA excuse
me NIH and NSF backed um startup company
that enables remote patient monitoring
using the Apple watch um I'm a visiting
scholar at the cipher Research Center at
UNC Charlotte which is an infectious
disease Research Center um and I'm the
author of genomics in the Azure Cloud um
I put some promotional copies of
genomics and Azure Cloud up here at the
front they're free um I would ask that
you you only take them if you don't work
for multi-billion dollar corporation
that can buy one so um and if you if we
run out come find me somewhere tonight I
have more in my room um in addition I'm
a Microsoft MVP for Azure and I'm a
Microsoft certified
trainer so in this talk we'll talk about
uh data storage and organization scaling
analyses with Cloud compute and then
I'll leave you with a case study from
one of my
clients before we get started I wanted
to say a few things about if you're not
in the cloud today so if you're work for
a Pharma company you're in Academia
you're doing everything on Prim what are
some reasons that you might actually
want to do something in the cloud and
some of those reasons include
scalability so in the cloud I can
immediately spin up or elastically spin
up virtual machines or clusters to meet
some sort of compute need and then spin
it down once I'm
done the cloud also enables us to deploy
large data repositories some of which
we'll talk about today and this allows
us to kind of dynamically scale and grow
our storage needs without having to
worry about oh I got to spin up another
database and I'm out a hard drive space
in the cluster the HBC cluster um the
cloud natively just offers a lot of
things that are collaborative so it
really Harbors collaboration across
teams because once we get our data in
one place and once we use shared
workspaces or or um solutions that that
are for uh compute or other kind of
analyses collaboration just naturally
flows and then because of all of these
tools are in the cloud and they can kind
of run um without a lot of Maintenance
we also allow it also allows us for a
lot of automation so meaning we can uh
automate very complex or long running
pipelines this is super important in the
bioinformatic space where maybe we have
a pipeline that runs for hours and we
want to automate that so that our B
informatics people can do something a
little more interesting in addition
since we're in a very highly regulated
industry the cloud offers a lot of
security um out of the box and then also
allows offers blueprints for um making
sure that you meet certain Regulatory
and compliance offerings or or
requirements but is not Idiot
proof so first data storage and
organization um I'm going to start with
a little metaphor which is unlike me if
you've ever heard me talk um how many of
you show of hands in your bedroom have
like a lovely little accent chair
sitting in the corner right seeing some
some hands but I think some of you are
liars because if you're like me the
chair actually looks something like this
right okay yeah I got some more some
more hands right and this is actually a
good representation of what like my one
drive looks like or Google Drive or
Dropbox because I some reason I have all
three right and it's a mess so thank God
for the search box because otherwise I
can't find my socks metaphorically
speaking so what we do is we want to
really start figuring out how to
actually organize that data rather than
just throwing it somewhere so
metaphorically speaking let's take a
trip down to Target or Ikea buy a little
cheap shelf this is our storage account
our data Lake and we can start putting
things on that shelf in the places that
they're supposed to go so now once
everything's organized if I need a pair
of genes and some Converse I know
exactly where to get them this is really
where we want to get to from a data L
perspective
right on this next slide I won't go
through all of these levels but this is
an actual slide from a a client Workshop
that I did where we really started
talking about how to organize data so
that you can be successful with a data
Lake across lots of weird types of data
that we see in the Life Sciences the pro
tip here is I always start with by
defining uh what is their the smallest
unit of work so in the bioinformatics
world we oftentimes start with a a set
of sequences or a for a single sample
and then if we start from that level and
work our way up in a hierarch manner
manner we get something to where we have
a a nice organizational scheme by which
we can place data as we get it this may
seem a little backwards like right
because right now like in your Google
drive or one drive you just kind of
throw stuff as you get new things and
hopefully make a folder and whatever but
in in the cloud if we can think of it
the other way plan ahead it really will
help us when we start needing to do
something with that data so for this
client they create they uh are a bio
manufacturing Institute and they develop
um stem cells for type 1 diabetes
treatment so they in their manufacturing
line they capture exomes for these stem
cells they also capture pathology slides
phenotypes lab data Etc you can see we
can organize by those individual data
types but they also kind of planning for
the future we are able to expand to
other studies and other clients and
other projects both internal and
external by this kind of scheme so this
is something that we would do at your
organization is try to figure out what
what all do you want to house in your
data
Lake just a little note here um earlier
this year Microsoft released one Lake
which is a unification system that
that's supposed to break down the silos
in data Lakes what was previously
happening is people would create storage
accounts or data lakes and then someone
needed access to it wasn't getting it or
it was Walling it off and so they just
go and create another one right it's the
originally the data Lake was supposed to
solve data silos in
databases but then now we just have data
lakes that are also siloed off damned
off what's the what's the anyway um so
here with one Lake um this is supposed
to solve that problem will it who knows
but the the goal of one lake is that
across the entire organization we share
a certain amount of compute that allows
us to communicate with different
workspaces in the one lake so in this
example here we might have a research
workspace that's preclinical and at a
Pharma company we might have an OM
workspace that is clinical and those two
can't see each other and different
people use those different parts but at
least they can be managed easier from an
IT perspective right keep the IT people
happy and in addition to this shared
compute we also have uh the concept of
One Security meaning through our data
warehouse or things like powerbi um I
can set a security protocol and it flows
all the way from the output all the way
through to the actual core data itself
so makes things easier kind of through
and through rather than having to
redefine Security on each of these
different Services which is a pain and
another thing that's really interesting
is that they're all in on the parket
format and if you're unfamiliar with
parket it is a distributed file format
it's really common in the spark world
where we can distributed in a
distributed manner read and write data
from data lakes and so as long as you
have data in paret format you can read
from any of these services that you see
here at the top in addition to data
breaks so why does the organization
actually matter though besides you know
saving you from turning gray by trying
to find some file that you threw in uh
you know six months ago the reason why
it matters is all about scalable queries
so using services like Azure synapse or
data bricks we can query across our data
Lake and answer more complex questions
in a much easier fashion so if I take
this pink box here as an example how
many of the sample how many of the
samples in studyb have gene erbb2
expression greater than 10 transcripts
per million across rnac analyses this is
an actual question that clients ask me
right and so are these others it
traditionally if this was all on Prim we
would have to go maybe to Network file
share go grab a bunch of files load them
up in R python filter them and then
produce this output it's the data
retrieval part that's the that's the
problem and so using this kind of
pathing that you see here at the bottom
you can see my data lake is organized in
a certain way where I can just drop in
some wild cards and grab everything that
we need to meet that that query need and
you'll see a little bit more of this in
the case
study while I won't go through this
entire example architecture because
you'll see a thousand architectures
within the next two days um one thing I
want to point out is that the cloud
storage is really sitting at the core of
the entire successful architecture it
serves as the landing place for when we
get all these heterogeneous data sets
coming in whether it's electronic
medical records if you're in uh at a
like academic Medical Center or lab
results or omix data or image data from
MRIs it serves as the single place where
we don't have to worry about we have to
worry about where it goes but we don't
have to worry about the file type very
much we also don't have to worry about
running out of space then the data l
also serves as the source for um more
advanced analytics like data warehousing
or maybe even data science and AI
workloads so we saw the llm Kino earlier
today in order to do your own llm you
kind of need your own data and it needs
to be accessible and organized um this
is this is a big deal right it's a major
requirement there and then also the data
lake is is the place that will serve up
for operational databases for other uh
frontend or um serving outputs like apps
uh powerbi Tableau dashboards or other
third party uh Sol
Solutions so once we have all of our
data uh in the right place it's
organized we're good to go now we want
to scale analyses with Cloud compute but
you may be wondering all right well but
I got this laptop it's cool it's like
you know I pay like $3,000 for this
thing like why why would I use the cloud
I could just use my laptop it works
that's true but you'll hit a wall at
some point with your local uh with your
local machine so y Cloud compute again
elastic scalability we can dynamically
scale up or back virtual machines
clusters whatever we need and then spin
them down when we're done saving on
costs we can also orchestrate complex
pipelines um and automate repetitive
tasks so which is really common in the
bioinformatics world where maybe we have
some QC tasks or we have tasks where we
want to process like sequence data and
it's the same pipeline over and over
again so why do we need to pay someone
to actually click that run button when
we could just automate those tasks and
instead especially for long uh running
analyses like a bioinformatics pipeline
that might take four hours we can then
scale using some of these cluster
services like kubernetes to instead of
taking four hours to run one sample now
it's 4 hours to run 50 samples at the
same time
right all of these tools also enable
analytical collaboration especially
things like data breaks and Azure
machine learning where you're all
working in the same workspace so you're
sharing the same code you're also
connecting to the same single source of
truth of data so it really helps to not
have this kind of everyone has their own
version or everyone has their own
environment that's that's weird and
wonky and doesn't match and all of these
things Harbor much better scientific
reproducibility which is which is super
important so I'll take a little bit of
time to talk about running R in Python
idees on Azure machine learning and
Azure data bricks and again if you um
don't run away if you're an AWS person
if you use data bricks on AWS or gcp
this also applies on those slides only
thing that won't apply is the Azure
machine learning part inside of azure
machine learning if you've used it
before you can create a compute instance
for those of you who are not familiar
this is like a virtual machine that's
managed and it comes pre-installed with
lots of data science pack packages both
in R and python but we can also go into
the advanced settings and create a new
application using a Docker image so if
you already have licenses for posit
workbench you can drop your posit
workbench licenses in here in addition
uh you can use an open source image like
The Rocker R Studio image um and and and
we once the compute instance is uh up
and running you'll be able to see posit
workbench or R studio in by clicking on
the little ellipses so this will serve
that IDE up inside of azure machine
learning so this is in addition to
Jupiter lab Jupiter vs code and terminal
which are already uh enabled on the
workstation um but then you also get
posit workbench if you do this well or
or our
studio so what's already included on the
Azure machine learning compute instances
as of the end of last month these are
the versions of python and R that are
pre-installed not a whole lot of options
or flexibility there um and then these
are the versions of jupyter lab and vs
code which are notably a little bit
older with the latest posit workbench
posit workbench image this the Jammy
image uh you get a bit more control you
can pick different versions um but the
the latest versions are python 310 R
4.2.3 and then you can see that in
addition you get R Studio Pro as well
and considerably newer version of vs
code in Azure data bricks um you can
also create a similar instance this is
we can create a machine learning cluster
or a cluster with the machine learning
runtime this ml runtime also includes
lots of packages that we already use in
the data Science World um and in
addition certain versions also include
our studio server so as long as you just
follow the directions of that and create
the cluster um with the ml runtime you
can under apps go and grab or go and
click the button that says setup our
studio server and it'll open in a new
tab so one of the big reasons for this
or there's two big reasons is one even
in our studio that opens in your new tab
you'll still have the spark back end so
if you want to use spark r or sparkly r
workloads no big deal good to go and the
second second is inside of data bricks
we can mount our data Lake and then when
we're writing our code we're just
pointing to a file path so it's no no
longer do you have to like download from
the data lake or from some weird place
and then reference a local path it's a
mounted storage location so it feels
like a normal uh local path
anyway if you're a python person or even
if you just like notebook style
environments you can also use the data
bricks notebook these notebooks are
polyglot meaning that you can switch
between R python Scala SQL markdown
shell
Java and some others um even all in the
same notebook so in this example that
I'm showing here I'm reading in some
drug sensitivity data from my uh from my
data Lake it's on a mounted storage um
and you can see I have pulled that Dr
sensitivity data in uh in a python or
pisar based data frame and then later
down in the notebook over here on the
right I'm doing the exact same thing in
R so and so we're I'm able to switch
back and forth and also these notebooks
are collaborative so you could have you
and your colleague in the same notebook
at the same time running different sales
in different Lang languages um so it's
pretty cool because we all know that
there are certain languages that do
things better for a certain use case
because a package exists right and it's
not always are and it's not always
python so we can switch back and forth
pretty
easily so I'll end with a case study so
I have a a client called Foundation 101
genomes they're a belgian-based rare
disease Research Foundation they um the
the owners of the founders uh started
this organization when they found out
that their son has Marfan syndrome and
for those of you that are not familiar
Morphin syndrome is a connective tissue
disorder that uh has two different
morphologies you're either kind of okay
you're just tall and lanky um or you
have a severe cardiovascular issues um
that results in death in a lot of a lot
of adolescence and so with this
Foundation what they do is they pull in
um lots of research data lots of lab
data from um patient generated samples
or participants in their study they also
have multiomic data coming in and then
lots of MRI and CT images of patients
with heart uh with with the heart
condition the heart style of Marin
syndrome so our solution was to have a
data Lake Centric design that allows for
us to query that data in Azure synapse
or Azure data bricks and also serve that
data up in other applications for
example the dicom API that you see here
on the slide so I think the big aha
moment for them was uh their research
lab that's a wet lab uh found in m in
mice that there is a specific mutation
in another Gene which I can't release
yet uh that is really related to the
cardiovascular the worst version of
Marfan syndrome and so then the question
was well do we see that in the patients
that we have in our in our cohort and So
within about 30 minutes I'm able in data
bricks to go and query all of the VCF
files or variant data uh filter to the
Gene and region of in interest and then
pivot by variant and look at this region
and see who is homozygous or
heterozygous or has the wild type uh for
that for that particular mutation or set
of mutations and then also overlaying
that information to see if it breaks
down between control and then also
people with Marans and people with
Marans with the cardiovascular disease
there'll be a paper coming out on this
hopefully later this year um so this is
kind of the big aha moment because being
able to organize your data in a way that
makes it accessible by these very large
compute Services means that we can
answer questions very quickly and then
hopefully eventually cure a major
disease so in summary running workloads
in the clouds in the cloud offers
scalability flexibility and automation
data Lakes offer a single source for
your data but it needs to be organized
to be useful it can't be that chair
right we can't just throw some socks on
there a and just promise ourselves we're
going to fold it later connected compute
Services allow for you to retrieve that
data um and and those sources really
feel if we do it right really feel like
we're working on a local compute context
meaning there's a really low barrier to
entry um if you're used to using just
your normal laptop and with that uh feel
free to connect with me on uh LinkedIn
medium or GitHub at kobby forward or if
you're interested in what I do you can
shoot me an email at kyle.xyz I'll take
some questions
[Applause]
thank you K Kobe appreciate it
so whenever you engage with a new team
what is like the first thing you try to
address when it comes to these kinds of
data leges I think the first thing is
looking at all of the different types of
analyses that that team works on because
then we can start to organize that data
lake at the very fine grain level like
all like if you're running clinical
trial do you do ihd data do you do RNA
seek do you do whatever like all these
different lab tests whatever it is and
if we kind of identify those things that
it helps us to kind of plan for the
future so to speak in in a data Lake
environment and then it also helps us to
understand do you have really small
analyses that maybe we don't need to
make some sort of complicated compute
architecture or do you have very large
workloads that you need to we need to
plan
for thank you um we got a couple minutes
if anyone wants to uh send over a
question uh I am curious though um do do
you usually get some like push back from
certain teams like not necessarily A
Team you working with but like an
ancillary team and typically which teams
are those there's a couple one of the
biggest things is since we're in a
highly regulated environment putting
clinical data in the cloud is still for
some reason very um makes people a bit
nervous which is really interesting
because um I've achieved GXP compliance
plenty of times have done things that
are on classified data Lakes like it's
it's it can be done and because of all
these overlaid um Blueprints and
Regulatory and compliance uh offerings
that you can overlay onto your Azure
environment it's really not that big of
a deal but for some reason it's there's
a there's a a gap there between
understanding that's one and then two
talking about the last talk right people
were saying there's this kind of bear
entry for moving from a proprietary
language to like an r or python um let's
say you don't want to move from that
proprietary language that cost millions
of dollars a year for no damn reason um
then you how do you actually run that
workload in the cloud or how do you
connect that service to um to a
cloud-based data Lake and it can be done
but it's not exactly as smooth as as
what I've it presented here well thank
you again appreciate it thank
[Applause]
you